okay
[Music]
watch the external
de it's a thing and we had to do it okay
I had to externally yield and and get a
yog on the projection point
but I want to at
contact I want to start the compression
the compression is right here okay and
then I keep increasing it as she's
driving I keep increasing it you see
that and then very small movements St
press so you can feel it okay so very
small movements
watch right there you see you see that
so if you watch my
external I made her do that but you can
see my hands mooved there you see that
so if she's driving driving I'll release
Here we are won't move there it is right
there right there okay so I'm I'm doing
that as we
go here
external
Pro r
boom boom that's external to
projection
in and you can see now I don't need
those external need to move my
arm don't need to move my arm okay so
that's
why in order to get the absorption I
have to release the tension and then
if I move my arms I'm probably not doing
the absorption so you keep tasking
yourself with less tension and L
movement okay all right who's
next that's movement
don't fight CU that'll always be
tension stay in their grips don't don't
fight the grip don't fight the grip F
the grip
don't fight that feel it feel words so
right here you kind of have that feel
that good
little bit High
better
it's
go
on for
so even if I even if I deviate you see
you still are doing the same compression
it's right here okay you
compress deviate
compress don't don't follow the same
turn
compress compress
um and then be cognant let me
show see how I'm trying to get out do a
graph so you can feel it see tr get out
okay what I do instead is you I feel
that you see and then inside I start
changing that
right even when I make your elbow go up
I don't go against the Thum so I grip
then I'm inside
so you have to be careful when you're
trying to do something to him because
that starts the contestation the desire
is contestation the desire can only
manifest because what is happening has
been made
undesirable do you see that so
instead boom this is what I work with
this is what I work with and my and
you're thumbs and your pinky on on the
slippage and all that is is is
indicative of whether I'm accepting of
it or not so careful like you want that
elbow up and you see you did a thumb
lock yes so
[Music]
inside okay try some more
okay any questions or comments yes the
compression speak up so we save it for
posterity yesterday when you mentioned
the the
compression and the release yeah um
sound of like you're talking about
everything yourself
but me as UK also feel compressed in
that moment yes so yes um
so remember
the the concentric epistm so what's
happening in me is happening in
you right do you get that so that's why
like uh even if you can't form your
tonden I can form it in you do you see
and then I control the toen in you do
you get that or even as uh you can't uh
release I can make you release do you
see that uh even if you can't experience
the Ecstasy of communion I can have you
experience the Ecstasy of communion do
you see that uh so that is definitely
something that's happening um and that's
how you stop the the
linking of the UK the UK is going to try
to link but they can't link because
they've been unified by my
unification
okay anything else I'm just really
feeling the thumb on Virginia a lot yes
uh when you were n or UK as n yeah as n
yeah and so and you know we do that a
lot in in our iido right we go
like we trying to get them off
balance um but this is a superficial
understanding of kazushi do you see um
and it's not in alignment with non-c
contestation or Wu way right and so we
have to go deeper what does non-c
contestation really mean total
acceptance you see um what is wo way
total acceptance right how can I do
total acceptance I have to lose the self
because the self is always a dichotomous
entity that concentrically expands out
dichotomy which is just contestation see
and so what we're use here is the poles
of the pinky and the thumb you see to
tell you don't push or pull don't open
or close just stay right where you're in
and seek the T Den in the middle which
is neither pinky nor thumb okay and so I
don't I don't fight you to get that kind
of stuff I use the motion and there's
the elbow right
now okay so try some more
so now let's hold ourselves
to inward outward
spirals this is in our
heart it could be
small but it's the
shape it's the shape
small see can be small or it didn't look
like it but inside it's coiling do you
understand the the two are coiling so I
don't have to go
outward inward but I have to coil all
right have the
coil
okay try it
you have to find the same y values but
with these
shapes
for for
[Music]
that's
okay any questions
comments less effort with the yeah okay
so what
I'm keep l
g and and let the
mudra do the work trust the m
[Music]
okay careful of these like if you're
fighting freaking do it but here we're
training okay all right
okay watch those straight lines all
right
yes make
spirals act
linearly l g
little more curve on the Y
hand okay so watch the uh
y hand here see that okay so we want to
go linear there all right you see that
and sometimes sometimes we turn him but
then it's linear there you see that yes
okay in or if I go spiral now I'm in the
shoulder that's part of the
problem again I'm turning him I go
spiral I got in the shoulder I missed
the center
okay that's why this is where the
internals come in I don't have to touch
I don't have to push the shoulder to
make the center go back okay so as
you're doing your spiral
here pay pay attention to that feel that
okay so as I do the spiral I'm not going
to pass you here and go into that
shoulder I keep disconnect
you see this that connection that
connection that pushed through there I
keep that connection on the spir you see
that it doesn't go in the shoulder so
I'm not going like that in the
shoulder but I'm not going like this
either I spiral
boom that that that part of the curve
from the vector that I'm staying
connected on is
linear do you see
so you you can spin a triangle it's now
a circle right you can you can hit with
a round object that that's kind of what
we're doing here so careful that you
like I feel I got him do you see that
and then you start pushing there
instead come around the tonden all right
all got that
okay
[Music]
better always stay out of the
shoulder better
better keep
Lal so this isn't L
yes
[Music]
better out of the shoulder
TI better
[Music]
all right stop there about the
compression and I just find it such a
fascinating sensation especially when
you're able to achieve it on contact
like you talk about
um but even when I'm kind of stumbling
along and going in and out of that
sensation
uh I guess it's because it's like
concentric with that body mind but the
experience is so
um God I don't know how to you what are
you talking about either in either case
there's
this
the there's just nothing left to really
think about or do because you just keep
that
sensation and then that experience will
just lead you wherever you might go if
you have the faith to stay in that kind
of relationship
then there's nothing to do or nowhere to
be and you just it just goes it just
goes exactly and that's that's the wui
state you see there there's no time's
not there space is not there those are
all dichotomous things you see okay and
the self goes so time the space goes
there's just that moment you just stay
in that feeling okay and and the same
thing happens to the UK you know UK go
like well I don't know what the
going on It's Too Late by that time you
see by the time they figure it out it's
too
late
um and I think as you watch watch the
video when you're when it's up you'll
see that I get more compression than you
guys so but you you're getting there
we're moving in the right direction but
my you you as UK get way deeper into my
body uh then you're getting your ukas to
do and that's just from the release and
the acceptance you see um the tension
the desire the dichotomy the self
manifest all that manifest and we start
the tension then the contestation now
you can't compress as deeply into the
nogget or get your UK compresses deeply
into you okay um but we're headed in the
right direction for sure okay but notice
that difference when you watch the video
like there there's a long time time
before you go boom back out do you see
yours is pretty quick on on touch it's
pretty quick um you kind of go like
you're still moving but I haven't moved
but you're still coming forward do you
see but I haven't really moved and then
then I finally bounce it back out the
decompression that happens okay so keep
an eye out for that okay